comment générer de la valeur ajoutée
quand on est agriculteur arnaud de
gourcuff a trouvé la solution se
diversifier sur tous transformés sur
site une partie de sa production 60
hectares de maïs du maïs seront le plus
adapté à son projet de pop corn
berrichon on a démarré le projet
grimpant en 2019 et on a sélectionné on
a on a testé des variétés avant 2 avant
de s'orienter sur cette variété qui
fonctionne bien dans notre terroir
berrichon ici dans le cher et plus
particulièrement à côté de dun-sur-auron
en champagne berrichonne un maïs 100%
bio co cultiver avec de la luzerne pour
conforter le sol et éviter les
traitements chimiques d'abord elle
apporte de la biodiversité est la porte
des fleurs les fleurs qui seront
utilisés par les abeilles pour faire du
miel d'une part et ensuite elles fixent
l'azoté atmosphérique la zone qui se
trouve naturellement dans l'air dans ses
racines et puis à un moment donné elle
est en mesure de la restituer c'est là
comme complément de compagne c'est le
maïs qui va récupérer la zone qui a été
stockée par naturellement par la luzerne
de gros travaux pour le stockage sont
réalisés dans la ferme il faut pouvoir
conserver 90 tonnes de maïs un produit
made in berry simple et surtout pratique
pour le consommateur prêtes à l'emploi
le maïs est stockée et ensuite on le
conditionne dans des petits sachets
micro ondable ces sachets sont
recyclables ssh et sont prêts à l'emploi
on l'aimé une minute trente à deux
minutes dans un four à micro ondes et
ils sortent tout chaud ils deviennent
des saladiers dans lequel vous avez
l'équivalent d'un saladier de pop corn
nature et vous pouvez l'agrémenter
bientôt avec des saveurs sucrées ou
salées banni des îles ou barbecue
à quelques jours de la moisson la marque
de pop corn grain pop est né cinq
personnes devraient être recrutées d'ici
la fin de l'année